-It is time for
"Tonight Show Hashtags"!
-♪ Hashtags ♪
♪♪
♪ Hashtags ♪
-Ah, very nice.
We do this thing every week
where I send out a hashtag,
and you guys --
ask you guys to respond
to that topic.
So with football
back in full swing,
I started a hashtag called
#NewFootballTraditions.
And I asked you guys
to tweet out some new ideas
for the football season that are
more appropriate for 2020.
Within minutes, it was
a trending topic,
so thank you
for playing along.
I appreciate that.
And now I thought I'd share
some of my favorite
new football traditions
responses from you guys.
This first one's from
@harlieghg.
She says, "Running through the
Lysol tunnel before kickoff."
That's actually a good idea.
We should get one here.
[ Light laughter ]
Uh...I'd do it.
This one's from @JEMetalHead96.
He says, "Instead of tackling,
players shout, 'Got you!'"
[ Laughter ]
This one's from @Grundy.
Ooh. Grundy.
-Grundy.
You would say it
as "Grundy"?
-Grundy.
It's in the game.
[ Laughter ]
-I think you're right.
This one is from @Grundy.
He says,
"Interviewing the winning coach
with one of those
long 'The Price Is Right" mics
to maintain social distance.
A six-foot mic.
[ Laughter ]
Uh...
This one's from
@Canne57.
Her new football tradition --
"Fifty cardboard cutouts
standing in line
for the bathroom."
It's like,
"Ah, you gotta be kidding me."
You got to make the experience
authentic.
This one's from
@tmomerling.
She says, "Facemask
no longer a penalty."
Ah!
-Ah!
-That's a good one.
That's a good one right there.
[ Laughs ]
Uh...
This one's from
@carriesmith1123.
She says, "Instead
of marriage proposals,
the Jumbotron
will just be used
to FaceTime
players' grandparents.
[ Chuckles ]
"Grandpa, the stadium can only
see your nostrils."
Uh, this one's from
@liberal nacho.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay.
-He says, "Coronavirus tip --
wear a New York Jets jersey
and you won't catch
anything."
-Oh!
-Hey!
-Whoo!
-Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa,
whoa, whoa, whoa.
This last one's from
@IntheZane.
In the Zane.
Yeah.
Get in the --
Get in the lane, Auto Zane.
-[ Laughs ]
-She says,
"After winning,
players say, 'I'm going
to Disney...Plus!'"
There you have it.
Those are our "Tonight Show
Hashtags," everybody.
Thank you so much. To check out
more of our favorites,
go to
tonightshow.com/hashtags.